dazu kommen meine lieben freunde ich
darf euch heute am dienstag startete
direkt mit positiven vibes in die
heutige folge
wer kennt sie nicht meine lieben freunde
die wunderschöne stadt italien direkt
neben dem wunderschönen land roben
[Applaus]
ganz kurz reizt diese frau jeden tag
durch ganz deutschland oder warum klingt
das wie bei gleich
vor allem habe alle halt immer so ja ja
geschrieben und es gab immer dieses eine
kind was so war so in die richtung so
dass man meistens da nicht läuft einfach
ein einhorn rum
warum laufen in allen ländern immer
irgendwelche tiere plötzlich durch die
gegend das einzige was ich hier in
hamburg brasil ist eine möwe mir heute
auch gegen fenster gekackt alltag und
die seitlich oder missverständlich
müssen
ich glaube jeder kennt diese scheiß
werbung
es ist schön dass du dein buch
verschenkt aber schmeißt es doch nicht
die ganze zeit so demonstrativ auf den
boden
die leute sind nicht so hohe wie du
denken
natürlich verdienst du irgendwie was
dran entweder über die versandkosten
oder dann ist er irgendwie ein
abo-modell drin oder da muss man ihnen
was einkaufen wenn man zweiter lesen was
weiß ich aber schweiz soll ich auf dem
boden das wurde ja nichts getan ist ja
die ein gratis exemplar was willst du
ich liebe meine freunde
also ist seit er ja auch irgendwie hin
gekommen
von daher würde ich euch einfach
empfehlen den weg wieder zurück zu gehen
aber schuldig das von einem kollegen nur
die pure gezeigt hast dass wenn es kein
geil leischik ist dann weiß ich nicht
mehr
also mir hat noch niemand so krass
geholfen die du jetzt gerade sie kommt
gleich mein pc punkt nächstes steht ein
budget gleich
er schnitt gefunden ist irgendwie witzig
aber auf der anderen seite ist es auch
echt traurig ich glaube jeder kennt
diesen moment wenn dhl kommt und man
sich denkbar da kommt das paket auf das
ich seit wochen wartet dann ist es
einfach irgendwie was für deine mama
oder so flott frisst was ist wenn etwas
gesehen hat was wir alle nicht sehen
weil wir zu alt sind
[Musik]
diese tickt auch videos wo die dann so
sagen ja lacht jetzt mal und jetzt die
augenbrauen dazu jetzt lachen weglassen
um mein gott das ist euer model blick
oder auch dieses komische wie wenn du
diesen filter anwenden das siehst du
welchem celebrity so ähnlich sie ist
nein man muss das bild selber vorher
auswählen das bringt nicht
[Musik]
ich finde das ist ein schlaganfall paar
sekunden später riss nicht weg alter ich
das nicht wecken damit vor allem ein
kommentar ihres ersten grand prix sieg
[Musik]
am ende hat komplett gekillt ich wollte
nur sagen wenn oder chat so aussieht
beendet beendet es egal wo sie vor ort
was einbindung gehabt ob ihr eine sekte
gründen wollte oder was auch immer ihr
machen wollte endet kontakt geht
getrennte wege
nicht so aber mit jedem wem schreibt
egal ob du ein mädchen bist du schreibst
mit einem anderen mädchen oder einen typ
schreibt mit dem mädchen mädchen mit dem
jungen julius scheint egal wenn ihnen
jemand dir schreibt was machst du gerade
und du antwortest nichts bei dir
[Musik]
sinnlos jetzt also das war quasi mein
leben in neun sekunden zusammengefasst
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was mit mir kapitel sorry
luca voll krass der hatte voll dass
claudia und so ey ich wusste nicht wann
darf sich genau das meinte ich gerade
als er das einhorn auf das auto zu
laufen ist überall auf der auf der
ganzen welt gibt es galerie tiere als in
deutschland
koalas haben die da waren horden und
weshalb wir tauben eichhörnchen die aber
den weg laufen wenn man nur das sind
sich auf drei kilometer hat es
deutschland teil
[Musik]
das kann ich nicht was andere schicken
oh wir schon relativ früh ich ganz
vergessen das meine zahnpasta noch eine
mikrowelle und ich muss noch eine open
kunst stellt also wenn es euch gefallen
hat daumen hoch
ein video abonniert den kanal wenn ihr
nicht vergessen dass immerhin ausgang
ist
[Musik]